I found something
I've looked at it from Every Which Way I
Am the smartest person I ever met and I
can't figure it out so I came to the
second you are up to something my friend
I've seen a million he's so-called
psychics each one of fake
I do not believe in psychics come with
me to a seance spot the con I can't
detective you are here to discredit me
but I can talk to the Dead
if all I have to
have to hit we are here listening
um
Felicia
what is happening
[Music]
you can't trap is here
somebody is dead
no one shall leave this place until I
know who did it a ghost killed her
there must be our rational answer for
all of this
just admit that you were up against
something bigger than you no
you were saying
something in this house tried to kill me
don't look at me like I'm suspect we're
old friends
every mother is somebody's old friend
no one shall leave until I find if the
living have been killed by the Dead
you have been hiding here all this time
who are you talking to
foreign